Jim Breuer the actor comedian performing
at the Knitting Factory in Brooklyn July
25th and Monday August 1st at 8:00
Eastern he's got a new album Jim Breuer
and the loud and rowdy
yes songs from the garage available now
yeah it's always good to see him you too
so I thought we were gonna play music
and it was gonna be you and Bryan
Johnson when you guys were on Howard
Stern and you you were doing a duet
weren't you well we weren't get it when
I was on Howard he was just he was
playing the song but there was no
intention of getting Brian to come up
there he's he's like 68 and legend
singer I know it Brian everyone he
doesn't need to
yeah he's in he ticket hey Brian you
going Howard
but do you sing at 7 a.m. with my little
song I know you're on ac/dc but you know
this is a big opportunity for you get
some extra tweeter yeah you know my
Brewer look yeah could you tour with
ac/dc oh god no you couldn't do the
songs no I could do three minutes of one
song but after two minutes my my vocal
cords like a machete was taken to it how
did how did he do that for all those
years I think he went the studio and I
think cuz back in black was the first
album he did and I think he went in and
you know maybe the producers like
alright lamb hear the song as black and
black son let's see what you got my
brain anyway which I just screaming it
just we've got a hit sing everything
like that love it wait two days play a
little bit more of a gym with Brian this
is a hot song take your time yeah it's
all good
and big build up to it big build up yep
it's gonna hit the post here lassie can
I come in second he comes in first this
is him okay
you can't tell the difference yeah but
you see den when you're loosing these
lyrics I can relate to you and your
pants yeah what do you think these that
song is the pants you're wearing
we're just taking chances yeah we're
taking chances I don't care anymore
I don't care either I'm 20 years I want
to be on a beach in Miami with a with a
metal detector with black socks pulled
up to my knees and my kids going dad
what he doing I'm gonna say nothing okay
write me during the commercial break
yeah you said something about the
deflator and deflategate in Mexico and
Tracy story and yeah I go okay wait
let's talk about it you go no no let's
don't and then you go okay I will all
right don't do that okay I was listening
you guys before with the the pilot
politics and ballplayers and all that
okay here's what I've learned over fans
you can get away with it doesn't matter
what the guy can come out and say I'm
into communism
I'm interdicted it doesn't matter what
they say as long as they prefer like
alright I'm a Mets fan
diehard Mets fan when they got Jose
Reyes back even before that bartholet
cologne had this big thing we're like oh
he's got another wife and kids and I
went from big sexy I saw me at a home
run and my first my wife said you know
what I don't like him anymore what now
hold on that's that's the culture you
know you know what I kind of you don't
know what's gonna I immediately defended
him and that's what a fan does it
doesn't matter what Jose Reyes comes
back you know you know he he yeah he
used his wife was really bad the first
thing I did which is horrible I went you
know you don't know situation he's in
Colorado he's frustrated she's nagging
why are we in Colorado
we should've never left New York you
can't hit anymore they were drinking you
know no but the fact that I defended
that so as far as a athlete saying I'm
Republican I'm for this guy it doesn't
matter when he hits the home run you go
he's my hero
well Michael Vick Michael Vick you know
any people you know you know you know I
wouldn't bought a pit bull for the guy
if he brought you to the soup ball yeah
you know some culture it's where he grew
up that's what happens but I can't
believe that the men thought about
killing a dog once am i right charlie
can you back me here this is is that
your fan voice that is my Dobie fanboys
that guy's got his shirt open and stains
on his belly
but then the Met fans giving Reyes is
standing ovation when he first came to
the plate about some nice golf applause
okay don't need a standing ovation
they're not we loved him
we he he brought the first chant back
then he brought the hose
that's the first thing I thought of when
I thought I missed him when he left I
was heartbroken so yeah I I gotta I want
to talk about what he did off the field
but on the field like hey the guy can
hit literally he said yeah he can actor
comedian Jim Breuer by the way yeah now
we can talk about if we don't know I'll
get to the deflator in a minute yeah
okay I want to ask you though as a
former Saturday Night Live cast member
if you were looking at who would be
ideal to be in the White House now based
on comedy not politics but comedy
Hillary or or Donald Trump Oh God
Trump not even close not even a not even
not even close Trump if Trump gets in
the comedians and the late-night talk
shows and SNL are gonna have a field day
he's easy to imitate he's uh it's just
it's so easy it's too easy he's got the
mannerisms he's he Trump is easy sees
get the hair his hair looks crazy but
their own cares his face is red why is
his face red like Hillary's not
interesting from a comedic standpoint
there's where Sarah Palin was Sarah
Palin was great killed a bear Canaan I
love shooting things and I don't know
anything about North Korea they have a
great barbecue place I know where where
Trump is a feel I mean come on we're
gonna build a wall
oh he's a professional wrestler do we
wanna make America great again then take
off your shirts and swing them don't
worry about your way to what you look
like let's show the war take your pants
off America come on like Jack Nicholson
there in a few minutes wings his shirt
he says his piece and anyone that has a
yellow hair and a red face has my vote
oh my god
I love him he's such a firestarter I
don't care about politics to me it
really is professional wrestling it's
professional wrestling all right take a
break take take a deep breath because I
want to come back so uh we'll get to the
deflator dude this was the crazy this is
what I realize how crazy fans are okay
this is this racy story I'm okay so
we're gonna we're gonna tease this yes
we're gonna talk about the guy who
deflated the footballs
allegedly and you meet him in a gym in
Mexico and and the yes okay all right it
might be a midlife crisis who knows Jim
Breuer actor comedian he's killing it
now Jim Breuer and be loud and rowdy
performing at the Knitting Knitting
Factory in Brooklyn on Monday July 25th
and Monday August 1st at 8:00 Eastern
songs from the garage is the album we
got some festivals too oh you do big
rock festivals I like who's your idol as
far as music yeah uh I grew up I'm a
hard rock/metal guy so gram the 80s oh I
am ac/dc metallica that's like my fine
wine right there bring me some nice
creeping death and some Merlot and sit
here and relax I listen to ride the
lightning
what about comedy Richard Pryor's Sam
Kinison or my are my big big exam
Kinison Richard Pryor and George Carlin
those though
worthy and today and whenever Chris Rock
has to say something I'm uh I see myself
waiting he he always he never
disappoints Sam Kinison Kinnison I mean
he imagined him now revolutionist yeah
well I think revelry he brought the loud
in stand-up comedy there was there was
no one loud until he showed up he showed
up and do you remember his first
broadcast he was on that Ronny
Dangerfield special and he shot he
started right off going stomp sanded
food to the Africans and you're going
cuz they're sitting there going don't
feed him yet camera angle wasn't good
and you stop sending these people food
will send him trucks cuz they who is
this guy and he did the whole marriage
thing he'd go to guys like you Mary Mary
yeah I love you Mac to you scrape
remember this face because when you
think about the delivery in comedy it
was you know very yeah but it wasn't
there um Sam was like electrocuting you
like he'd shot you like you just zapped
you
he was the first a Taser comedian Steve
Martin was the first quote Rockstar
comedian and selling out big arenas and
stuff like that Sam Kinison was the real
rock like rock and roll star where he
just he brought in he brought in the
rock crowd he he would I stopped Dice
Clay was a rock star to correct he was
right there yes hands down dice with me
he was selling out the garden oh god I
went saw him I saw him twice in the
second time I saw he was playing drums
like what are you doing because he could
I'm gonna play the drums now because I
want to
all right the deflategate yes the
deflator so it should be mentioned you
have no idea really what no here's the
stand I don't care okay I don't care
whatever happened at the end this is my
I I hate the Patriots okay I hate them I
respect them as a team but I have to
hate them I just did one the team's it's
just you eight everyone hates a team I
hate the Patriots whatever yeah I'm like
this team they're at they're phenomenal
they're my Braves the bright hate the
Braves because they just kill the Mets
oh and to be dead a series deflategate I
don't get let's say they did deflate the
ball you still gotta intercept it why
did it why does the offense have a
bigger I don't get it stupid okay get to
story okay you're in Mexico I know I'm
in Mexico and I'm doing just for Laughs
festival there's a new resort the
Riviera whatever it's me and through the
sky peak or yell he's really funny and
some other comics and the resort is
doing big promo alright it's it's like
half price for Canadians and you come
there and wear it we're down there right
so it's raining one day and I go into
the gym a big beautiful gym two stories
right it's just me and I'm in there and
all over TV is the deflategate thing is
so obnoxious it's like he like he
invaded Libya or something it was so
stupid and it flexes to the left and
clearly that's a sign of a liar I think
here's to him out of football relax
so this guy comes over to me a big a
pretty big guy a young guy and he walks
up to me I hope my kids die if I'm lying
comes up to me and he goes would you uh
what do you think of all this and I'm
like I don't want it to you know I'm in
a gym I don't talk to any why is he
gonna start I didn't know fees he's
gonna hit on me I what's going on here
why you why are you walking up maybe
notices me
thinks I'm bait cuz I look little just
go lift and wait bird like that so uh he
goes how much time do I have your seat
I'll hurry though like two men okay okay
long story short he goes I'm on the
deflategate guy Oh what I didn't believe
him at first and he started telling me
he tells me his name I could even tell
you it's a Polish named John or whatever
his name is
so just strum ski just shamsky yes Jim
Stransky yes okay he starts telling me
about the deflategate all this and he
kept saying Tom's my guy's the greatest
kind of world but I don't know what's
going on you know I'm not allowed to say
anything the Patriots like there do you
know the payment said what are you doing
here cuz I can't hate mail and the fans
and they want to kill me and we don't
know if we're gonna move this is owing
job ever had in my whole life and then
his wife comes down from upstairs and
she's even more upset like you could see
the human side these are just two
innocent people and they're going we
don't know if we gonna have a job we're
not allowed to talk about it and I keep
saying we're gonna take care of you but
they have to say anything but we're
gonna find out more when we get back and
I said why don't you come to comedy you
know we have a comedy show and I gave my
email and he emailed me back is like
sorry I couldn't come last night we went
to bed early but so I go on Sports
Illustrated and say this I don't know
anything I don't know this is such a big
deal so the fans in New England I go so
let me go just right you're the German
you're talking to deflategate guy and he
just told you everything
yeah Bruce are you careers in the dumper
you gotta have stories up why would I
want to make up a story
did you ask him if he did this I swear
my love I did not ask him I was praying
he would tell me and I guess I tried to
lure him in I'm like come on my podcast
and well you need to get us out please
yeah I met him and we talked about Jim
Breuer actor comedian he's performing at
the Knitting Factory in Brooklyn Monday
July 25th and Monday August 1st the
album Jim Breuer and the loud in the
rowdy songs from the garage yeah I got
two videos thrash and old-school check
him out good see
guys Bubba Watson take the shirts off
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience